[Musique]
allez une les variantes du corona des
russes très présent en moselle au lit et
veyran fait état de 100 nouveaux cas
quotidiens
le ministre de la santé qui se
déplaçaient dans le départements du
grand est
aujourd'hui il a annoncé une
intensification de la politique de tests
de vaccination dans le même temps
l'agencé européenne des maladies appel
se préparer à ce que le virus reste
parmi nous sans la suite du procès en
destitution de donald trump au sénat
place aujourd'hui au réquisitoire de la
défense les avocats de l'ex président
américain espère l'acquittement rapide
de leur client accusé d'incitation à
l'inspection lors des émeutes du
capitole en janvier le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères menace l'union
européenne de représailles en cas de
nouvelles sanctions contre l'occ ramla
en cause des recommandations du chef de
la diplomatie européenne de pénaliser la
russie après l'expulsion de trois
diplomate européen ayant participé à des
manifestations illégales en soutien à
l'opposant russe alexeï navalni
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france la situation en
moselle est inquiétante selon le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand qui
s'est déplacé dans le département du
grand test aujourd'hui un nombre
important de cas de variants sud
africain et brésilien du coronavirus y
ont été détectés
on y recense en nouveaux cas par jour la
plupart il s'agit du variant sud
africain face à cette situation les élus
demandent des restrictions plus sévères
françois grosdidier le maire de metz
demande que les vacances scolaires
commencent dès ce soir pour l'instant le
gouvernement prévoit un renforcement des
tests et de la vaccination
écoutez olivier ferrand j'ai annoncé
d'abord que nous voulions intensifier la
politique de tests sur le territoire de
moselle qui est pourtant déjà un
département parmi ceux dans lesquels on
teste le plus en france tout cas
positifs de coronavirus sera désormais
considérée dans ce département comme
suspect de variants jusqu'à preuve du
contraire c'est à dire qu'il bénéficiera
d'un contact racing renforcer immédiat
d'une mise à l'abri accompagné immédiate
d'une durée d'isolement porté à dix
jours contre 7 jours un test pc red pcr
sera réalisée avant la levée de
l'isolément et un test pcr sera réalisée
dès le premier jour chez tous les cas
contacts éventuels
par ailleurs et à la demande des élus
locaux jeu dé renforcer la politique de
vaccination dans le département de
moselle
je tiens d'abord à préciser que 75% par
exemple les personnes âgées on n'est pas
dans déjà reçu au moins une dose de
vaccin dans ce département donc il ya
bien vaccinés c'est un département qui a
déjà été soutenue lé plus que d'autres
compte tenu de l'incidence épidémique
qui était plus forte
eh bien j'ai demandé aux préfets à la
directrice de l'hôpital de médecine bill
de maintenir des centres de vaccination
ouverts ce samedi et ce dimanche et deux
mille doses supplémentaires de vaccins
moderna pourront être mises à
disposition de la population notamment
les personnes âgées de 75 ans et plus
dans les tout prochains jours nous
indiqueront également aux équipes
soignantes du département qu'elle
pouvons disposer de davantage de vaccins
files heures pour pouvoir continuer à
protéger de manière intense cette
population
ollier révérend qui recommande d'
intensifier donc la vaccination alors
que l'hôpital de saint lô dans la manche
a suspendu la campagne pour les
soignants plusieurs membres du personnel
ont déclaré des effets secondaires pour
après avoir reçu le vaccin astrazeneca
et ce n'est pas le seul hôpital
concernés on rappelle qu'en france plus
de 2 millions de personnes ont déjà reçu
une première injection de vaccin
les précisions de notre reporter katia
technique encore des déboires pour la
campagne de vaccination le vaccin
astrazeneca est administrée depuis
samedi dernier aux soignants de moins de
65 ans et depuis
eh bien les remontées négatives afflux
ce vaccin provoque chez certains un
syndrome grippal avec de forte fièvre et
des maux de tête au point que par
exemple de 20 à 25% du personnel
soignant vacciner du chru de brest se
sont mis en arrêt de travail en si le
tablissements brestois a décidé de
suspendre sa campagne même chose à saint
lô et l'hôpital de morlaix qui devait
débuter sa campagne et bien ne l'a
démarrera pas en tout cas pour le moment
alors jeudi soir l' agence du médicament
devant laquelle je me trouve
actuellement a informé avoir reçu 149
déclaration de pharmacovigilance
entre le 6 février et le 10 février au
matin
il s'agit de 149 sur 10000 vacciner ans
qui finalement fait relativiser avec des
syndromes grippaux souvent de fortes
intensités fièvre élevée courbatures etc
fallait qu'ils surviennent chez des
sujets plutôt jeunes de 34 ans et cela
ne dure qu'un ou deux jours alors les
effets indésirables selon l'agent sont
connus est prévue avec ces vaccins il ne
s'agit pas d'un problème de l'eau
défectueux mais l'agent ça fait une
recommandation que les établissements
xtion leurs injections afin que le
personnel soignant ne subissent pas les
effets secondaires tous en même temps
très sèche et encore que la france est
le premier pays à recommander une seule
dose pour les personnes ayant déjà eu le
coc vide par ailleurs nous allons vivre
avec le co vides selon l'agencé
européenne chargée des maladies sa
directrice a déclaré que le mot
doit se préparer à ce que le colis de 19
reste parmi nos fins la hongrie a débuté
aujourd'hui sa campagne de vaccination
avec les scouts nick v seul pays de
l'union européenne a autorisé le vaccin
russe la hongrie fait donc figure
d'exception parmi les 27
quatre hôpitaux de la capitale ont
commencer les vaccinations
plus de trois cent dix mille personnes
ont reçu au moins une première injection
d'un vaccin
et selon les autorités budapest acheter
un nombre suffisant de doses de spoutnik
v pour traiter un million de personnes
est suffisamment de doses du vaccin
chinois sinopharm pour traiter cette
fois 2 5 millions deux personnes je vous
propose d'écouter la chef du service
médical en trois mois
aujourd'hui nous commençons un geste il
vaccin spoutnik à notre population
les doses de vaccin seront répartis dans
les cibles de vaccination désigné
environ 560 médecin de la capitale ont
sélectionné cinq personnes de leurs
établissements qui ont ensuite été
envoyées aux centres de vaccination
auprès de 2800 doses de vaccins ce pique
nique seront administrés neige
aujourd'hui ne l'en quête en chine sur
les origines de duke ovide oms annonce
que toutes les hypothèses restent sur la
table la mission des experts a duré un
mois on n'écarte pas un sens l'hypothèse
que le virus proviennent de l'institut
de virologie de la ville comme l'a
prétendu l'administration trompe on
écoute le représentant russe de la
mission qui estime lui qu'un animal
serait à l'origine de la transmission du
corona des ruches un ouf
chaud chaud chaud comme il l'est nous
savons aujourd'hui grâce à l'expérience
des pandémies précédentes notamment
celle de sarko et de mère scob que la
source de la pandémie est une chauve
souris
nous savons également que les chauves
souris sont porteuses d'un virus
génétiquement proches du virus qui a
causé l'épidémie actuelle
nous trouvons chez les chauves souris
des virus apparenté au sart skov 2 il
s'agit de nos connaissances générales et
cela n'a rien à voir avec les données
recueillies lors de cette mission
cette chasse nous savons également que
le virus n'a pas été transmis
directement d'une chauve-souris à
l'homme mais via un hôte intermédiaire
il ya eu un autre animal avec le sar
skov c'était une civette avec le maire
skov c'était un chameau donc il doit y
avoir un autre animal ce n'est qu'une
hypothèse fondées sur nos connaissances
se ne la veut pas dire que c'est en
réalité ce scénario qui s'est réalisé
c'est juste l'hypothèse la plus probable
fondées sur nos connaissances actuelles
et en espagne les catalans sont appelés
à élire dimanche leur président de
région une première depuis 2000 17 et la
déclaration d'indépendance qui avait
provoqué la destitution du gouvernement
régional de catalogne quatre ans après
la pandémie de comics 19 à estomper la
question indépendantiste reportage à
barcelone d'aurélie chamois avec quel
récit de francs soit 10 km h
[Musique]
au siège de cette puissante association
indépendantiste pandémie oblige il n'y a
guère d'effervescence à quelques jours
du scrutin régional
ici on vit encore avec le souvenir du
référendum d'indépendance de 2017
mais la ferveur n'y est plus le camp
indépendantiste pen ar motiver ses
troupes
depuis des lourdes condamnations
prononcées à l'encontre des
organisateurs du référendum et de
l'incarcération des leaders politiques
responsables de la déclaration
d'indépendance alors ces élections c'est
peut-être l'opportunité d'un nouveau
souffle cette année très compliquée à
cause de la pandémie mais aussi à cause
que la citation ce ne n'est pas
améliorée du tout on a toujours les
prisonniers politiques ils sont toujours
en prison
on a eu encore plus de réprésailles y
ait encore plus de monde qui est en
train d'aller en prison que de passer
par les tribunaux
donc même si quelques parties espagnoles
sont en train de dire qu'il dit qu'il
faut tourner la page et regarder vers le
futur
ils ont ils ont fait rien pour ça donc
l'état d'esprit de banditisme maintenant
c'est il faut gagner encore une fois les
élections ils font encore une fois
démontré qu' il n'y a pas de solution
s'il ne passe pas par un référendum ou
par l'indépendance si le débat
indépendantiste s'est un peu apaisée
dans la société catalane
il reste néanmoins la question centrale
de ces élections mais pour les opposants
au projet indépendantiste
elles sont une opportunité d'entamer un
nouveau cycle j'espère vraiment que ce
seront des élections de transition et
que le rôle qu'ils joueront les partis
constitutionnalistes sera essentielle
cela dépend d'eux et de leurs devoirs
envers les citoyens pour que ce soit
vraiment une étape de transition et
ainsi pouvoir mulliez tout ce que nous
avons vécu durant ces dernières années
des dernières années marquées par une
très forte participation
cette année l'abstention devrait être au
rendez vous en raison du contexte de la
pandémie
et dangereux moins important que les
années précédentes ces quinze dernières
années la participation est allé en
augmentant son score le plus fort a été
bien sûr en 2017
juste après le référendum
indépendantiste
cette année à cause de la pandémie mais
aussi de la fatigue sociale est d'une
grande partie de la population la
participation et la fluence électorale b
seront sans aucun doute participation de
la floride
dès dimanche soir la catalogne aura des
résultats mais il faudra encore attendre
les négociations de coalition pour
qu'elle ait un nouveau gouvernement
la suite du procès en destitution donald
trump au sénat et le réquisitoire de la
défense qui a débuté après
l'argumentaire des procureurs démocrate
les avocats de l'ancien président
américain visite en acquittement rapide
de leur client accusé d'incitation à
l'insurrection
ils doivent ainsi prouver qu'il n'ya
aucun lien entre les discours de donald
trump et l'assaut du capitole par ses
partisans
ecoutez-le un angle un de faim bonjour
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président l'article de mise
en accusation devant le sénat est un
acte de vengeance politique injuste et
clairement anti constitutionnel cette
effroyable abus de la constitution ne
fait que diviser encore davantage notre
nation quand nous devrions essayer de
nous rassembler autour de priorités
communes la nouvelle administration
américaine qui ne semble pas vouloir
changer de cap dans le conflit boeing
airbus en lien avec la sphère en janvier
dernier donald trump a intensifié les
taxes sur les produits européens depuis
17 ans que le bras de fer dure les états
unis et l'union européenne ne cesse de
s'imposer mutuellement des taxes joe
biden ne devrait pas revenir sur celles
imposées dernièrement même s'il souhaite
se rapprocher de l'europe selon la
chaîne
l'américaine si nbc emmanuel macron a
proposé de régler ce litige fin janvier
lors d'un appel avec son homologue mais
pour le moment il n'y a aucune avancée
sien on en parle tout de suite avec
christian de boissieu les vice président
du cercle des économistes
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france pourquoi
l'administration by john revient pas sur
cet axe imposé dernièrement par à donald
trump
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de continuité
entre les républicains et les démocrates
sur ces sujets moi j'ai jamais pensé que
l'arrivée de monsieur by des néo
démocrates allaient changer les
relations avec l'union européenne ou les
relations avec la chine
donc nous sommes encore dans un contexte
conflictuel alors l'organisation
mondiale du commerce est censé améliorer
les choses mais vous fais remarquer que
c'est l'om sait qui est autorisé chacune
des parties a finalement un toit hier
des taxes donc à réagir par rapport aux
initiatives de l'autre partie donc boyau
mc jouer noté quelques années âge un jeu
assez dangereux je répète vous l'avais
dit dans la présentation tout ça dure
depuis 16 17 ans à propos de boeing et
airbus ont ce taxe mutuellement nos
importations
quant à que les exportations l'autre des
boeing et des airbus
et je répète à mon avis il américains
vont pas nous faire de cadeau sur ces
questions là à puisqu'il comprend la
chine crs pour le mcc le conflit
commercial le plus long le plus
difficile à traiter aussi pourquoi est
ce que c'est si difficile parce que
derrière vous que derrière tout ça vous
avez des l'enjeu économique et
géopolitique
airbus et boeing sont quand même les
deux les deux leaders en matière de
fabrication d'avions
il ya des enjeux de souveraineté et et
chacune des parties depuis celle 17 ans
puisque ça a commencé en 2004 accuse
l'autre partie de subventionner sa
production à travers des aides
appel des aides d'état bon et puis voilà
donc on s'installe là dedans et en
consommaient pas autour de la table en
essayant de progressivement
progressivement j'allais me réduire et
de façon réciproque des taxes imposées
sur l'autre partie
on n'y arrivera pas il y avait cette
escalade qui a commencé bien avant 30
qui a commencé en 2004 l'om c'est à
carder faire de manière un peu passive
mais l'om c est aujourd'hui un organisme
international faible à mon avis assez
bloqués donc on est dans le bilatéral et
on va voir si le président macro et il
prédit en byden arrive à se parler
si l'heureux représentant pour le
commerce
pour nous c'est c'est l'union européenne
un qui va négocier sur tout mais je
pense que monsieur macron a un rôle à
jouer vis-à-vis de bruxelles et
vis-à-vis du négociateur européen donc
moi je souhaite une désescalade des
taxes pour les relations entre les états
unis et l'union européenne
mais ça ne me paraît pas gagné alors du
côté de joe biden c'est vrai on le sent
vouloir véritablement assainir les
relations maintenant avec l union
européenne
vous parlez vous évoquez emmanuel macron
qui lui aussi va aller dans ce sens ce à
quoi s'attendent finalement est ce qu'on
peut espérer au final à un dénouement du
conflit témoin je n'attends pas
grand-chose dans les mois qui viennent
il y avoir un écart entre les mots et
les choses entre les intentions et la
réalité est ce que l'union européenne va
parler d'une seule voix nous sommes pas
break si donc nous sommes 27 pays
européens être concernés par les
négociations est ce qu'on va être 27
pays est d'accord sur la manière
d'aborder nos nouvelles races et les
nouvelles relations avec la nouvelle
administration américaine
du côté américain c'est plus simple
puisqu'ils sont tout seul si je puis
dire c'est un pays et ils ont pas ils en
passe coordonnées à priori mais moi je
pense qu'on va être dans ce contexte
compliqué et je souhaite qu'on vienne
vraiment des relations multilatérales
vous avez vu que la nouvelle
administration américaine va revenir
probablement alors laurie nation
mondiale de la santé qui reviennent
autour de la table pour les problèmes
d'écologie il revient il revient dans
l'accord de paris dans le dos la coupe
21 vis-à-vis de l'om c'est du commerce
et des taux de change moi je vois rien
de changé de voie de la continuité
surtout qu'à un autre conflit celui de
la taxe sur les géants du numérique qui
vient un peu se superposer à celui ci le
conflit entre boeing et airbus ya la
menace aussi de nouveaux droits de
douane sur des produits français encore
comme les fromages les produits de
beauté ou les sacs à main là encore est
ce que cela risque un peu plus
d'envenimer finalement ce le bras de fer
que l'on connaît déjà et les relations
entre les etats-unis et la france
particulièrement le web ce chercheur en
matière de taxation des gaffes à
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'accord vraiment au
niveau européen et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la france a menacé la première
sa propre taxe sur les gaffes et tout ça
ça crée un climat de défiance mois
plutôt que d'imposer les gaffes
américaine je préférais que 1 du côté
européen par une politique industrielle
audacieuse au niveau de l'europe
on essaye d'aller vers dés la création
de gafsa européenne je pense que c'est
ça la bonne réplique aux gaffes
américaine ces buttes suis pas sûr que
la bonne réplique ça soit une taxation
d'autant plus que les pays européens les
27 sont pas aujourd'hui d'accord entre
eux sur ces problèmes de taxation des
gaffes 1 donc tout ça ça crée un climat
de défiance
je répète il faut vraiment et ça c'est
un problème politique c'est une option
politique de part et d'autre amorcé une
désescalade
mais quand vous regardez l'histoire
américaine des administrations
démocrates n'ont pas été plus gentille
avec l'europe que les administrations
républicaines de pas plus gentil avec
l'europe ou avec la chine donc que là
c'est un domaine où il ya de la
continuité à mon avis entre républicains
et démocrates
merci beaucoup avoue christian de
boissieu d'avoir été en direct avec nous
je rappelle que vous êtes vice président
du cercle des économistes un autre
dossier important pour les états unis et
l'union européenne le dossier nucléaire
iranien dans un communiqué berlin
londres et paris demandent talleyrand de
respecter les termes de l'accord de
vienne lui reproche de produire de
l'uranium métallique en violation du
plan d'action global commun après le
retrait en 2018 les états unis de
l'accord de vienne terran a commencé
progressivement à s'affranchir de cet
accord on regarde à cette réaction un
tweet du chef de la diplomatie iranienne
mohammad javad lari nos partenaires du
e3 ont-ils déjà lu le paragraphe 36 des
accords de vienne et les nombreuses
lettres de l'iran à ce sujet au nom de
quelle logique un combustible à l'iran
de renoncer aux mesures de sauvegarde
prises
un an après que les états unis se sont
retirés et continue de violer les
accords de vienne café 2 3 pour remplir
ses obligations
autre sortie ce vendredi celle des
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov qui fait état de
représailles russes envers l'union
européenne en cas de nouvelles sanctions
contre moscou une mise en garde après
les recommandations de son homologue
européen josep borrell de sanctionner le
kremlin après l'expulsion de trois
diplomates européens de russie accusée
d'avoir participé à des manifestations
illégales en soutien à alexeï navalni
l'opposant russe dont une nouvelle
audience de son procès en diffamation
s'est tenue ce matin à moscou les
précisions justement avec notre
correspondante là-bas verhaeghe hoffman
la russie est prête à une rupture des
relations avec l'union européenne c'est
ce qu'a déclaré le chef de la diplomatie
russe sergueï lavrov dans une interview
à une chaîne youtube soloviov live
le ministre a quand même souligné que la
russie ne voudrais pas s'isoler de la
vie mondial je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait de son intervention sur la
sérieuse on nous partons du principe que
nous y sommes très heureux au cas où
nous verrons une fois de plus comme nous
l'avons déjà ressentir puis du 3 mai
que dans certains domaines des sanctions
qui crée des risques pour notre économie
y compris dans les domaines les plus
sensibles sont imposés ce week-end
nous ne voulons pas nous isoler de la
vie mondiale ils vont être près de
l'origine
non si vous voulez la paix pour préparer
la guerre le porte parole du président
russe dmitri peskov a précisé que la
russie ne souhaitait pas une rupture de
relations avec l'union européenne mais
devaient être prêtes écouter les médias
présentent ce titre devenu sensationnel
hors de son contexte l'idée est que nous
le souhaitons pas nous cherchons à
développer des relations avec l'union
européenne
messi lui eu poursuit dans la même
direction nous y serons prêts voilà ce
que le ministre voulait dire si nous
faisons face à une politique extrêmement
destructrice portant atteinte à nos
intérêts la russie doit être prête à
l'avance à entreprendre de telles
démarches
nous devons être autosuffisant nous
devons assurer la sécurité dans les
domaines stratégiques les plus sensibles
et nous devons être prêts à remplacer
tout ce dont nous risquons d'être privé
par une infrastructure nationale
mais c'est au cas où la folie
l'emporterait cette déclaration de
sergueï lavrov concernant l'éventuelle
rupture de relations avec l'union
européenne intervient une semaine après
la visite à moscou du chef de la
diplomatie européenne josette borel ce
dernier a fait savoir via son porte
parole que l'union européenne était en
train de préparer de nouvelles sanctions
à l'égard de la russie mais ce travail
apporte un caractère confidentiel
les relations entre la russie et le son
pour reprendre les paroles de genève
boel au plus bas à cause de la situation
en ukraine et en biélorussie mais aussi
au fait de l'arrestation de l'opposant
russe alexeï navalni et détention de
plusieurs manifestants lors des
rassemblements non autorisés le 23 et le
31 janvier en russie
en équateur le socialiste et andres
arros ne connaît toujours pas l'identité
de son adversaire pour le deuxième tour
de la présidentielle qui doit se
dérouler le 11 avril prochain il est
sorti vainqueur du premier tour les
écarts restent serrés et certains
candidats dénoncent à des fraudes
électorales et précision avec à robin pu
l
les partisans des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle commence à s'impatienter
depuis plusieurs jours des centaines
d'indigènes équatorien manifesté dans
les rues de la capitale quito pour
soutenir leurs favoris à la présidence
de l'équateur yacou perez selon les
résultats encore provisoires du premier
tour publiés ce jeudi cet avocat
écologistes arrive troisième du scrutin
avec 19,40 2% des voix
il est devancé de peu par le
conservateur guillermo olaso crédité de
19,72 % des suffrages et donc pour
l'instant qualifié pour le second tour
mais devant ses fidèles
yakou perez dénonce une manipulation ils
commettent une fraude flagrante et ce
qu'ils font c'est laisser endommager
gravement la démocratie la démocratie
actuelle est une caricature un théâtre
de mauvais goût cela m'attriste
terriblement ils ne veulent pas les
votes pour rien coup perez ils veulent
tout un projet tout un rêve tout un
espoir que les équatoriens avait le
candidat indigènes réclamant recomptage
des voix dans plusieurs provinces dont
les quatre qui ont le plus grand nombre
d'électeurs au premier tour une demande
soutenue par son adversaire guillermo
olaso de son côté andrey saros large
vainqueur du premier tour avec plus de
32 % des voix exprimées demande à ses
rivaux de garder leur calme
nous appelons tous les acteurs
politiques impliqués dans ce processus
électoral à être patient à agir avec
prudence et nous appelons à la
non-violence à maintenir une situation
pacifique
tous les autres points à résoudre dans
le cadre du processus électoral devrait
être réglée dans le respect des
principes démocratiques et des
mécanismes institutionnels approprié
alors que le conseil national électoral
n'a pas encore publié des résultats
définitifs
la mission d'observation envoyée par
l'organisation des états américains
recommandent elle aussi aux candidats de
faire preuve de responsabilité et à la
population d'attendre les résultats dans
le calme
en attendant le conseil national
électoral est protégé par l'armée
envoyées en renfort
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
dans 30 minutes à rester avec nous sur
rtl
[Musique]
des accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région avec prague était le
seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est